So we are in our application.
We've been rendering that front_HTML form, that's what we've been editing.
Let's go ahead and add our
post function to deal with
the user types list.
Okay, so we add the post function.
The first thing we need to do is get the parameters out of the request.
Self.request_get ('title')
and self.request_get ('art'),
and that will get those values from the
posts from the form submission.
Let's go ahead and add some basic error handling.
Okay, so I've added the shell of our kind of error handling.
So if we have both the title and art,
for now, we're just going to say thanks, you know, that's just a stub.
If we don't have a title in art,
we're going to say--we're going to set this error variable,
and then we're going to render the form with our error message.
So I'm going to pass the
error variable I made into this function render,
which is going to pass it to our template,
and so we need to add a place for our error in our template.
Let's put this right at the bottom of the form.
Okay, so I've made a basic div.
I'm going to call it class error, because I have
intentions of styling this later to make the text red,
and classes are how we attach CSS styles to things.
Now what I want to do is I'm going to say
},
and then I'm going to close this div.
Now what this does, this is part of our template language.
This includes the--any variables that the template is rendered with.
It will render them right in place here.
So this is a little bit nicer than the string substitution thing we were doing before,
and while I'm in here, I'm going to go ahead and add
a submit button because we forgot that before.
So we're going to give this a test, here we are in our form.
If I click the submit button without submitting anything,
we render our form and see our error message, that's perfect.
If I type in just the title, and I click submit,
again the form with the error message.
Just the art, perfect,
and now if I type in both, I see thanks.
Okay, so it looks like this thing is working.
One thing I want you to notice is when I type
in text in the text field and I hit submit
and we get our error, we lost our text.
Remember we've dealt with this before,
so let's go ahead and fix that bug while we're sitting here.
The first thing I'm going to do is I'm going to
pull out the rendering of the front page into
it's own function because we are going to be calling it
from both get and post, and I don't want to have
some of this logic that we're about to write duplicated.
So let's go ahead and add a new function to our class.
So let's create a new class called render front,
and this is going to render out front page.
It's going to take in a few parameters, how about the title,
which will default to nothing,
the art work, which will also default to nothing,
and the error message, which also will default to nothing,
and all this function is going to do right now is it's
going to call self.render front.HTML,
and we're going to pass in title equals title,
art equals art, and error equals error.
All we're doing here, and you should remember this
structure I hope from the previous lesson,
we're just taking this variable title and passing it in
to the template and so we can use these variables
in the template when we're rendering our form.
Now what I'm going to is I'm going to replace
this call of self.rendered to self.render_front.
That will draw the blank form, and them going to
replace this call to self.render to self.render_front,
and this will render our form with the error message,
and one final thing we need to do is actually make use of these variables
so let's go ahead and do that.
Here we are in our input for the title.
Let's preserve the title
so I'm going to do--I'm going to include the title variable passed in from the other function,
and then in our text area, I'm going to include
any art that was passed in.
Okay, let's give this all a test.
Reloading this page doesn’t break anything.
If I type in a title, and we're testing--
we're going to test our error submission,
and I click submit, we should see our error message,
and we should see title still in the title box.
Hmm, okay, we see her error message but we don't see title in the title box.
Let's go investigate why.